Aaron Sampson here with the top five
reasons
battlefield hardline needs a sniping
focused mode I've heard a lot of people
say they hate sniping in battlefield
it's cheap recon players don't play the
objectives that slows down gameplay and
who really wants to be suppressed or
taken out every time they transition
capture points but ever since people
stood atop the tower on Oman or hung out
on the cliffs of demo van peak ever
since people got their hands on a gold
Magnum and Bad Company 2 if they're
being honest with themselves Landing a
long-range headshot is probably the most
satisfying thing they've ever done
outside of c4 creeping in the
battlefield game that's why people spent
malko 3 Mavs elevating and battlefield 4
helicopter ditching or spawn beacon
parachuting to every piece of
conceivable high ground they could find
whether you want to call it sniping or
just sharp shooting here the top 5
reasons why it's time for the Recon
slash professional to get a mode in
hardline number one the mix of urban and
a floor map design and hardline is
already perfect for it dustbowl produce
some of the best bolt-action fights I've
had in a long time
players stuck deep inside urban houses
firing at elevated positions at the
water tower or shooting from the radio
tower to the mill it was a map that
proved running guns sniping can be a lot
of fun and more importantly useful to
playing objectives other maps in the
beta such as Downton offer an entire
skyline of high-rise buildings just
asking for marksmen duels number two the
gears already there the starting sniper
rifle the scout elite sporting a
medium-range scope and straight pull
bolt was one of the most useful
out-of-the-box sniper rifles I have seen
in battlefield in a long time the
grappling hook not seen since
battlefield 2 Special Forces is finally
letting those specialists climb in non
game-breaking ways the zipline leads to
quick flanking and evading
high off the ground the sheer freedom of
movement with these tools equals a lot
less camping which is what most people
usually hate and leads to a lot more
fast-paced range combat which is what
people enjoy also the spawn beacon being
handed to the engineer means no more
whack-a-mole number three sniper rifles
damage vehicles in hardline ever since
the recon player lost the mortar strike
post Bad Company 2
they've been left staring at distant
tanks and ellaby's with really no good
options
hardline has changed the equation by
allowing both action rifles to deal
significant damage to most vehicles
including being superb at shooting down
helicopters translation it's a fair
fight
number 4 LEvolution you can just kill
that word already has more of an impact
on the professional class if you're a
class other than professional the dust
storm really doesn't affect you that
much
a sniper duel on that map would have
distinct phases the first part would be
more methodical long-range combat the
latter phase ending with close-range
secondary weapons as visibility drops
overall evolution with the professional
is just more meaningful and number 5 a
change of pace is kind of nice
I'm not saying that I want to play a
sniper focused mode all night long but I
am saying I would appreciate heist
Hotwire and other modes much more if I
could take a patient group every once in
a while
weird I'm getting a tower mixed mode
playlists make it hot then slow it down
for around
so what would your ideal sniping
centrist mode look like in battlefield
did you catch that awesome co-op sniping
mission from battlefield 3 drop them
like liquid do you hate snipers do you
really just hate yourself or do you just
hate snipers that don't btfo leave your
thoughts in the comments below and we
will see you in about a month when
hardline releases
you